every the big bad world trying excuse me
excuse me man will heritage of Israel
better and give up and thank you that
you can't give up
buddy what will get me
all right Jerry we did a nice little
talk last time but I'd like to do the
same kind of cover your whole story from
start to finish and I'll just do a
little more comprehensive talk than we
did last time
so before before you were shot but what
year were you shocked what year was it
o-o it you know the way to 13 years it
was about way to you that thing that's
way too so 13 14 years ago really
yeah so it's been a while do you and
what were you doing before then you
would here at a full-time job
how does me see this machinist and he
airplay puts airplane parts and you were
married single you have kids Siegel kids
Lou no kids okay and were you ever
integer like drugs or gangs or anything
like that
no yeah how do you play sports used to
be I think I was the best player and
your owners magazine calls treats it
smooth
was it a magazine called streets in
Smith I don't know it wasn't easy
they think there's Wayne Street okay
but Keith my teacher related to my cabin
say it was the line with that and UC
Berkeley and UC goodness a high school
that's why go - yeah let's go into class
with my cancer so we only got a point
yeah my name is Danny I think the closer
again maybe that's one of the top 25
best ball player in the state of
California all right and would talk to
the 50 bats more please in the United
States Wow baseball with a little
basketball so your graphic yeah tell me
some more
that's why three years it was me ten you
go to a grade and there's new guys you
like me why is that house itself let's
try living with seniors oh you're you're
good for your age how bad the coke
because I didn't say voice when I were
you it may be a problem
that was beneath you and was problem
guys like me could stop troubling to you
about seems I was trying to reclaim with
her so so when you were shot you were
going to work you're coming home from
work
good little boy coming home from work
and said anywhere at bus stop and what
happened there's an do I look when I
thought I was dreaming
attack totally happy to me you see it
you know yeah you can't believe a
surprise but sitting I believe is with
the items but divided because because
point-blank weights
he said when playmates do a bit roll
down the street and skin of you came up
with it I have your vision
the fish gets a skin graft scheme I just
came to give it to him on these days
it'll be yeah and I got squab yeah it's
big my vision is like the guys won't
help
so you lost one eye and your other eye
yeah yeah yeah and then she shows
everything you look good
I cannot breathe or spill out my nose
can you taste yeah you can taste and she
doesn't read like a reading would you
can't read cuz your visions yeah I'm
tired now so how long were you in the
hospital
oh there for one of the years yeah and
the other day you asked me
how'd you go to rips well I read through
that I'm sorry risk loss an immediate LT
of material a reputation silly oh I said
read sukumaran soon like that yeah of a
few yet you been here a while so the
surgery must have been incredible they
said Twitter sooo sad something like oh
it takes a million that we made with
Romanian I'm sorry
it's the way that my legs you put it
it's all about you our vein listen I'm
sorry please no Lenny I've never seen
your arm you always have to talk over it
you see a scarf do you think I can do
this
it's wheels up so what do they do to
your hand
hey wait this yeah isn't it great
this one's like that will you do it okay
[ __ ] more like this yeah I can't say
that much
oh you can't straighten it that is good
it's only two hey like this who's paying
I give it a Sling right and you tell it
to a giri take the page do that that's
what and that's what I did it was it
just we gonna sit you madam at my screen
and everyone like this I said well over
sitting at this that's why the tubby
keep it out that plane just takes pain
they wanted to break it
let's get out and you define that what
you put his already your bow is sticking
out only what did you do it so did your
hand was shot it was an elbow the elbow
a shot every way are you right-handed
looking with living let's go Paul
what's up on you
yeah [ __ ] it yeah
it says you'll read it was really okay
that's what man character
yeah neither and as you say see the
pills yeah you told me that you took
seizure pills medications
this will tak to me surgery with
anything do you think I'll make it to
say no it's the same I said [ __ ]
eejits [ __ ] you know stop again but that
uses have legacies that seems to already
just come on I like to achieve more time
I stated I devised a chicken then I'll
go through these all the chance I would
like to get the fighting skill Guardian
story so then you kind of everybody said
joke on the camp and come all the to
your storage way and then I took a
Google I pass angle your senior
personnel seems to like it
no if I was in there I said never to use
every single young street now but it's a
deal first Street in their corporate
name yeah you know tell me another
quarter
Stephanie useful data showed every night
and we were in there think about their
school USA with you and it sounds with
an s birthday you ago
how many thanks to go same time so I
think we did super shoes here was right
ever supposed to look legacy Zeleny we
have to me and whatever - yeah no yeah
TV they say they will team up I seem a
little realtor came over us again sir
Jerry you see that scene you girls with
all daniel face you say I'll call the
ambulance will you
you try fighting you scan with a live
yes nobody told me
you said you tried take one good food
they use personal home again and you
stupid failed attack totally and you
know the way the seizure the seizure
medication I knew you see you said you
see this Cup idea yes here it was wide
open you say man I see you made it like
a [ __ ] one on your face they call mmm
he said you can wear you can fight you
and then you grab a girl to host it
means resolutely and then you script if
you're honest I got to look good like me
a little I believe it you know me to
reach that's up taking stuff and the
best case you're doing it you never know
bad yeah man I'm ready new because no
where did you go
are you invited myself you were somebody
else and again on it you can be trying
to kill me it's gonna be it's gonna be
like that I remember and you see me as
you listen yeah you don't remember hello
there's any stuff so he did and anyone
says do my same thing
i walking wealthy by my business this
bill behind me i walk then whenever this
room ready so I won't say - what up and
then if you get it you right there
before you - freeway right all the time
wasn't walking in silence we know we won
of course these good that his way along
with them I didn't walk off your the
sack look what she looks like obey you
ain't gonna quit me you think we lose
that I take is that what you want cause
you're driving like that again it was
just I was named Oh God doing that
welcome to dam freeway and well kill me
through I see it's about a [ __ ] anyway
so anything closely on the damn ceiling
that's a little sweet sidewalk was I was
in our way to thank you from someone and
it sounds good there was not going
sensory oh yeah
and of course runs appraisers it won't
be able to say it grew do it walking
right by your face if he's ready this
mean exit the senator through an exit is
but a [ __ ]
you're walking on the freeway Oh what
were you did you do it walk that foot
properly close my eyes it was gonna
sound crazy like that you cross the
freeway
yeah I want the ones that run since our
shows now right
hey why do you sound so don't like this
announcing with him like didn't want
other side
Oh cause it's that what is that
quite a boo-boo cuz your vision so that
way I won't be good at walking and then
you every right with it
actually selling whatever right I think
this about a [ __ ] that's inside said
thanks st. Peter it's one way that they
were flying those people a day and so
you know I want one free did that know
do the nighttime little bit I like that
yeah yeah so so the guy they never
caught the guy who shot you
and you don't know who did it you never
saw it coming
this is no they never caught the guy
left en route
singing you've seen on you if I know
about dogs dreaming
I know the answer he said 20 out of
surgery and knows this yep
this is the other week this one guy told
me I've ever seen you see me it is you
doing it well you remember they took
months similar would a buddy something
like that you could call it remove that
from a chimpanzee right yeah yeah they
said he said they got unity a miracle
mr. Merkle local history miss nettle
would you guys provide whatever Tina
yeah they rebuilt her face yeah yeah
okay is it you got me the little miracle
history book will be supplied we happy -
yeah yeah what's up - Lee video a video
get internet and what guys show me the
cover CD look perpetually oh that's yeah
so do you feelings of anger towards us
personally
sure I'll have a video g'day I do I
still go to it I never eat this yet you
bring any yeah roofie tell me call me
well stir I will take as many people
teach you Thank You chef yeah
yeah I came afraid you guys though we've
got it which is good
were you religious before you I hear you
mentioned God a lot everything were you
religious before you were shot
oh we did with you you work but with a
kid with a church hey you better sit let
me say this bad mood if she could write
and a happy for anybody's back before
everything turned everything that we
said okay do you see them right now
losers and musical so do you have a dear
family
ok it tells me they do well then I know
where you are if I know they were fun
you know tattoo with women in him I'd be
swapping you to be a panel with any good
idea yeah just love yet so is your mom
so much
yes hello and she doesn't contact you we
better do did you have contact with your
mom before the accident
yeah yeah but not lately
yeah what's changing I said
where was your dad but they're too much
to be passed away with me to us but
feathers good group itself
I was just with one we're gonna say I
placing you attendance in my plan
you've seen me more times than you've
seen everybody in 2001 was set at 7 3 mm
yeah he will help bill to was it right
yeah you think you know yeah I guess
make it a little bit
it's I had that real ready go I'll come
in ok never will but he wasn't really in
your heart no love and your childhood
was good yes yeah nothing nothing crazy
went on yeah we'll get with another your
mom took your line yes that's great you
have any friends sure what are your
thoughts on forgiveness
there's nothing if you come again for
the Fothergill gets the gift first
that's forgiveness you you can't forget
you came to get when you say so is that
anyway what you do
you forget completely you wash it clean
okay you won't forgive you forget okay
forgive we all forget yeah yeah it never
it never happened yeah if you're still
hanging on to the fact that that
happened you're not really forgiving
this is it they said this I'm not saying
it could wait but this would say too bad
you say no and I can use it when says
right here chance to King there's
simplification
there's somebody to bounce in there
ferry again as we say the bad well that
saves a great wave of take this we say
matters so much money that's it
sage what you can accept that's it
we're to Kate and tested I'm suing I get
a change with Yuki hey it's Jeff with
you Kate
so Jerry if you could have anything in
the world anything you want what what
would it be your will be happy
Happy's with night know who was
everybody able to eat they liberated
those is I mean everything
nothing for you to adjust then that mean
for me a nicer place for Joe and that's
been to the whole world
this Debbie anybody you all be had do
the society
who's easy yeah that's a beautiful
that's a beautiful that's the most
beautiful answer you'd ever get you
you're an amazing guy here yeah hey
what's up is doing any good
what why I give you Regulus what is it
with you you get a radio is with that
you let me go get your radio oh yeah
it's the first time you've ever asked
for anything
I give away the best yeah I'm asking you
anything in the world you want a radio
okay a radio
I'm asking if you want something like
significant you're saying a radio so
Jerry do people ever give you like kids
every react to you like they're scared
of you or stuff like that so they'll be
still hate it's a boob lat
even a dopey what do they think that
you're like deformed or boo like this
yeah to make it sweet and sweet you know
oh I see that good separation to me
thank you buddy
maybe they'll never do something else -
yeah - oh my god yeah yeah and you be
for my god - Hanson we're saying buddy
and their friendship is read to me what
he said you know bringing this crystal
yeah it Chris was the bed I guess it
could work that way were there some kids
something else boy I blame it so
beautiful you got some skin and I people
call me Dave Ruthie well they're like to
me
what's your view of the world do you see
the world is a mean place cruel place or
a loving place it could be the little
place where I can see that is just about
what you mean sim went away again it
could be people that pull you back it
will see me so you guys know that it's
really you trust again in the living
flesh
definitely
anyone will be there's one if you had
the world in him as one of the end of a
Russian doll world that's would one day
agreement immediately
you
you